[Music]
as school boards move toward the left
concerned parents give them an f between
mass mandates critical race theory being
labeled domestic terrorists and gender
policies more confusing than rupaul
buying drinks at ladies night
parents have a lot to be pissed off
about but biden's top cop attorney
general merrick garland is leading the
war against mom and dad he's got more
issues with parents than britney spears
republican lawmakers grilled him over
his horrid memo directing federal law
enforcement to review threats against
school board members garland tried to
clarify but dug a deeper hole
first sentence of your memo the very
first sentence you said in recent months
there's been a disturbing spike in
harassment intimidation threats of
violence yes when did you first review
the data showing this so-called
disturbing uptick
so i read the letter and we have been
seeing over time threats
i didn't ask you so you read the letter
that's that's your source is there some
study some effort some investigation
someone did that said there's been a
disturbing uptick or you just take the
words of the national school board
association
the national school board association
which represents thousands of school
boards and school board members says
that there are these kind of threats
so let's target parents uh based on the
school board association letter
demanding that he target parents
this isn't based on any actual data no
facts no stats no cases just a letter
that's pretty scary and if you're scared
you should be when a group of people can
write a letter to the attorney general
demanding you get targeted and he agrees
that's some seriously bad
i might
i might try that
on my neighbor who keeps playing
coldplay
i hate coldplay
earlier this week parents in michigan in
virginia filed a lawsuit against garland
accusing him of trying to criminalize
free speech and if that's not enough the
cdc now says schools should keep mask
mandates even if the kids are vaccinated
so mr president what's up with this war
on parents
i don't know what these parents are so
upset about let the schools do the
teaching all right you're not an expert
in how to raise your kids
look they teach
the four r's in school reading writing
arithmetic
vaccines
[Applause]
and
you know the song
school days school days
dear old golden rule days
what's a golden rule wear a mask
heather i was just saying we never we
don't have a war on christmas anymore
we need a new war and i think they just
delivered one it's the war on parents
and the parents have have to at some
point galvanized because their kids are
like the most important thing i don't
understand it but you know
you have kids i wanted yes i'm one of
those moms and and i think the world of
my daughter everyone thinks that their
kids are the best in the world of course
we're all biased uh as parents but
you're right this is a big push to take
away power
from parents and shout out to all those
that are speaking up against us i mean
for example critical race theory is
divisive it's un-american it's very
destructive and i think the federal
government should stay out of it you
leave it up to the states and that way
you you keep the authority with the
parents where
if you don't want your child to go to
that school they can go to a different
school and here's where it's really
hurting democrats in the polls you look
at uh in virginia terry
mcauliffe his his poll numbers are
tanking he said that parents should have
no role in uh and parenting their child
and even democrats aren't aren't voting
for him the the school is not the
ultimate authority it's the parent yeah
whether you have a child or not rob
yeah rob this president was supposed to
unite a country but he is he's uniting
the country against joe biden i mean
that's that's united i don't know what
you're first telling us how he was gonna
do it first of all you know you like
coldplay oh i don't know all right but
ever since he heard poor gwyneth paltrow
yeah right her feelings broke her heart
but i would say this is that the the
origin the problem is is that the
parents are finding out what's going on
in schools yes the minute they find out
what's going on in schools the minute
they actually like watch or read or
because of them at home school board
meeting they're like wait what what that
what
so the problem isn't for these guys
isn't that the parents are protesting
the problem is the parents now know
what's happening yeah and you it's hard
it's hard to shut somebody up once they
know just what you're doing in their
name exactly you know kat they the
no one seemed to mind when people were
accosting people at brunch
or chasing down you know people come
leaving restaurants or going to the
theater but now you if you dare cross
the school board
yeah and i just all of them say follow
the science
quite a bit for people who don't
have science
like there was a letter that's crazy but
it's it's you know par for the course
it's where's the science that says
you know you don't need to wear a mask
if you're a year and 11 months and three
weeks old but once you hit two years old
you better put that mask on or else your
whole family is murder family yes
they say that
they do obviously they do you know chris
uh it's amazing to see the attorney
general
make his decisions based on stuff i see
on tv and this letter this is amazing
he's not tweeting this seriously no it's
and by the way so my husband's a public
school teacher you have a husband i know
what happened
my husband's a public school teacher in
frederick county virginia yes and he has
said for years and years that the most
important thing in determining success
or failure for children is involvement
of the parents that when he has
parent-teacher conferences with failing
students guess what parents never show
up right the a-plus students the parents
are always there we ought to be
encouraging parents to take a role in
their child know what's going on in
their schools instead we've got the
federal government threatening to roll
out the patriot act against parents who
are concerned that is absolutely
ridiculous it's insane
but having said that it gives us so much
great content oh yeah
all right before we go
a quick reminder come see me on my book
tour i'll be in birmingham alabama next
month and lovely newark new jersey in
december ticket info
lap it is beautiful g gutfeld.com hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else